welcome to this video yeah it's a funny
pairing playing against a friend of
minor if he's yeah is he never updated
that I am he's a GM now of course yeah
enter said this is a grandmaster
Danielle house hot Daniel but um yeah
it's been a long long time teammate of
mine in various leagues and teams in
Germany Holland whatever so we apply a
modern defense which is probably not the
wisest choice but I didn't really think
about it that much what I thought I
played out yeah he's rated 25 something
also in and over the board yeah that
looks a little bit like in hippopotamus
yeah that kind of stuff is actually what
he plays himself sometimes so not sure
how clever this choices but anyway we'll
see and there was really a case where I
just put some moves out it was really
surprised that I got him hehe it's not
really a regular five-minute player as
you see is very high rated but he
doesn't doesn't play in that rating pool
usually okay i was thinking at t5 might
be good on the e5 i have 90 form yeah
that doesn't look too bad if i get that
Bishop i'm pretty happy yeah okay give
me the bishop i will take it it's not a
big problem for why do anything just
that i was glad to to get the bishop so
what she was now and what he m knight to
e for as a possible move that he might
play shortly also Bishop before maybe I
wonder about his plans there
Castle acquires a his spread a 4 and h4
makes it difficult to castle and I
wonder if he has got some very
aggressive ideas like sacrifices maybe
this one fixing the pawn on h4 and
allowing Bishop to h6 okay so he doesn't
mind bishop age 6 okay okay it's got 95
the night is heading towards g5 I guess
hmm yeah definitely true
yeah I wonder if he can sacrifice some
wear them after 95 let's say if I go
Rukia fade that's the sacrifice
definitely looming I am okay now give
fate he might really just take somewhere
96 or something yeah the alternative is
to just snap off that night come on
let's grab that night intending a
possible night before it doesn't mind
that the sea go what does he do Queen
there for something anyway I play that I
can get a bishop I will I will take that
opportunity hmm so
okay said something that I already don't
mind can i pre move here I think I can
with the D file okay yes a possible
queen to f4 but can't have it all so if
I go route d7 Queen f4 am now that sets
an annoyance definitely hmm about
difficult difficult to do something
about it at the moment okay just
grabbing grabbing some space and I
preventing queen before thats it's
really important actually so it's that
way to activate stuff it's amazing how
annoying that node is
I don't really have an idea in this
position that's really awkward I'm
really awkward to play
well it's amazing how bad this position
is I really have no activity whatsoever
a5 my back fired you to be formed yeah
it's not that I didn't see it but it was
just just far too late look T for maybe
I'd have seven queen of eight it's not
working maybe I can get some count up
Jay with Roxy for what it's it's
interesting okay trading looks awful the
Queen e8 also sucks but ok that renews
the idea of route chief or maybe I can
take on high morning and take a left
seven then wow what a bad position
amazing yeah I don't see anything here
that Queen trade is also not great but
it's just too bad
rook da toads
96 I don't know I didn't I just move the
bishop it was silly and I was a very
stupid move I could just move that piece
with no matter no very silly I'm still
under sleep problems or would have had
problems but I could have just played
that different Jack Jack Jack LaRue gets
no squares absolutely no squares it's
cute you can go all the way over to
evade okay i need to give me allow me a
hash of chicken I egg k doesn't matter
probably check amazingly bad position I
could have taken taken the bishop again
I was just too bad black resigns there
was just too bad the position okay so
let's see here Gavin this should be
quite okay actually so here here black
is totally fine i just played it badly
probably the next couple of moves are
problematic h5 might be might be bad
actually now that that's a bad idea
ready the night coming to g5 is a
problem a big problem yeah the engine is
very simply stating that after c5 black
has a huge advantage
it's may be true yeah they're the comp
give c3 after that white is essentials
why does in big trouble strategically
with that that just is just at this
terrible of what yeah maybe c5 was the
way to go I mean he gave up its dark
squared bishop but but h5 was it was
really bad that was really bad came and
now I should cancel and still am much
better yeah maybe I haven't but I can
absolutely don't believe that this is
great for white cannot believe it but I
couldn't prove that Ruby for as much
better yeah I played that's so simple i
had just in two simple ways and this is
this is also a clear advantage home like
now i miss many chances here this is
just sucks it really sucks that the
engine gives like an advantage she has
kind of a joke Queenie aid is the
computer suggestion for Quincy six
probably yeah okay that's stronger of
course then what I played clearly
stronger yeah as I see yet that that is
a point as really as a point something
like that and okay you can take here but
I have rocked it to then cute so that is
the point I have to this is this is this
is a big problem that I allowed this hmm
the engine still likes my position after
Quincy five yeah I took a lot of
mistakes to make my position really bad
even here the capture and c5 is okay
according to the comp yeah that that is
that is the problem look before was
still ok yeah I don't know but it's a
it's not easy to play it was just very
uncomfortable disposition with him
sitting there on the dark squares the
the funny thing is that this is this was
just a weird idea oops I can just move
that piece and and go from there somehow
like here I don't know how to see wynia
I mean I have have summer oops sorry
that was where you be it I have some
ideas there for myself with the pawn I
don't know it's the Lord winning the
engine is just giving a slight edge I
don't know I could have fired for David
was too much pressure on the position
and a lot I should have really um finish
this thing in the opening at least
getting a clear advantage that that that
c5 was was giving hmm anyway it was
interesting game thanks for watching